[Music]
[Applause]
chris mannix set to join us manik's a
senior writer for sports illustrated and
uh he was there covering the eastern
conference final or eastern conference
semis as the boston celtics pick up the
win over the milwaukee bucks mannix
joins us on the program felt like that
this was a a hall pass year for giannis
you win the title you're mvp you don't
have chris middleton but
you get the feeling milwaukee's going to
be back in this position next year don't
you
yeah i agree um you know when a team
goes out you start to do these
post-mortems on them and
in those moments you're often looking at
worst case scenarios what's like all
right well they lost the second round
what's the significant change that needs
to be made
to get them to a championship level even
with phoenix
you know
they're still good themselves but you
start talking about chris paul being 37
and looking like a 37 year old over the
last week or so deandre ayton's contract
the
expensiveness of that team will robert
tsar repay the luxury tax with
milwaukee
it really is just kind of get chris
middleton back in the mix and make a few
changes around the the periphery now
look i think the dante de vincenzo trade
really hurt that team in this series um
they could have used d vincenzo i
understand why they made the deal
a few months ago they made the deal to
get serge ibaka because they didn't know
the health status of brook lopez at that
time so you had to have an insurance
policy in the middle for the playoffs
and ibaka
nominally had enough playoff experience
to get you there but
as i watch game seven and i'm watching
grayson allen struggle wesley matthews
struggle those two guys one for 11 in
game seven i'm thinking dante de vagenza
would have been pretty valuable in in
one of those roles so you need someone
like that and some help on that bench if
you're milwaukee but you plug chris
middleton
back onto that team and you start next
year as one of the top five
favorites to win the nba championship so
it's not
you know
it's not you obviously need some things
to go right to win titles but this bucks
team if they bring this group back whole
you can make an argument they're right
there at the top of the nba
are the sun's frauds
no i mean i i
you know you start to get some like
you know during this series the way they
were
mocking luca at times i mean like i i
don't know why you want to poke that
bear in the way they did it kind of
reminded me of how
condescending the miami heat were in
2011 towards dirk nowitzki remember that
with like the fake cough and and all the
stuff like there was a level of
arrogance to that miami team in the nba
finals that caught up to them i mean the
the mavericks were not as superstar
laden
as miami was at that time but they were
the better team and they came out and
showed it and like early in the series
there were some pot shots taken at luca
a little bit later in the series you're
talking about the lucas special and how
he's flopping and falling down things
like that i just
it felt a little
over the top especially for a team that
hadn't won anything that had gotten to
the finals last year and you know lost
to the bucks in in six games so
yeah there's that part of it but frauds
no i i just
as i wrap this series up dan i i go into
the offseason wondering what chris paul
has left in the tank at this point i
mean games one and two look at the
numbers games one and two he was
excellent like 24 points per game
something like that you go to game three
which not coincidentally is when he
turned 37 years old um and from game
three on he was bad he was averaging
under 10 points per game
in that uh that stretch in the last two
games he was awful so
it's almost like you know
he turns 37 he got old like literally
overnight
in that game so i go into next season
wondering did we see
did we just see kind of a change in
chris paul is he going to be able to be
the player he was
during this season or
do we now have to accept that chris paul
is
while still a high-level guy
uh maybe going to be something of a
diminished version of his former self
moving forward yeah he turns 37 luca
just turned 23 in february like he's
doing things
you're not supposed to do this he's not
he's not but don't you speaking of like
vibes off of teams like
yeah look the mavericks are good the
spencer dinwiddie trade was great for
them jalen brunson is excellent but
don't you get kind of some like oh six
cavaliers you know it oh seven with the
team that lebron kind of strapped to his
back and took to the finals that year
that team had some good players like
larry hughes was good eric snow was good
but there was no
there was no stars on that team like
don't you get a little bit of that with
this dallas team like yeah you know
they're good players and those players
showed up in game seven you know
phoenix's role players did nothing
dallas's role players did everything but
you know luca outscored the suns in the
first half of that game by himself like
how often do you see that i mean this
this to me feels a lot like that lebron
year where he just took the cavs
into the finals with a bunch of guys
that were good but nowhere near you know
championship level talking to chris
mannix sports illustrated senior writer
if you were going to describe luca to
somebody who hadn't seen him
what words would you use
larry bird but a better ball handler
i mean
he makes the kind of shots that bird
made you know and i grew up watching
larry um turn arounds
fadeaways
effortless three-pointers um
he can just do more with the ball i
think than larry bird could have done um
in his best days uh he i mean that
that's that's pretty much it he's he's
bird with better ball handling skills
i couldn't help but think of the boston
celtics as i'm watching them demolish
the bucks that brad stevens decided not
to coach and went into the front office
like
when you think that i mean that's
shocking because it wasn't like he was
old
i don't think health was playing an
issue he went into the front office
i it was one of those oh by the way
moves where you look back yo that's
right he used to coach this team
this team would not be in this position
if brad stevens was still the head coach
and
i say that as a person who
back when brad stevens decided to step
down and then step up into the front
office i was pretty critical of it i
didn't think that brad stevens was the
right fit
for a front office role i thought in a
way he was taking the easy way out you
know he had been
worn down over the previous couple of
years whether it was the kyrie season
which took a lot out of him or the
bubble season which took a lot out of
everybody i thought at the time
you know he was looking for something of
a cushier gig
in that front office but
brad stevens recognized at that moment
the celtics recognized at that moment
as good a coach as brad stevens is and
he still is an excellent coach
he had run his course with that group
his coaching was no longer resonating
with that group and they needed
a coach who was effectively the anti
brad stevens that's what imei udoka is
he as
smart as both of these men are
his coaching style could not be more
different than brad stevens from a
philosophical standpoint where he came
in and brought this switching defense to
this team that they hadn't played in
years past which helped propel them to
the top of the nba in defensive rating
to more importantly
uh
a
sterner voice someone that was willing
to give this team a public whipping
after bad losses um in the first part of
the season imei odoka one of the big
reasons he was number two on my coach of
the year ballot was because people
looked at the first two months of the
season as being bad i looked at them as
being great coaching imayodoka spent
those first two months
breaking the celtics of so many bad
habits they had atrophied over the last
year or so under brad stevens so imei
odoka had to break them up that habits
to get them in the position in january
where they started to turn things around
and the second half of the season where
they were a top three team in the entire
nba so as much as i like brad stevens as
a coach and
i believe he will be a coach again
someday and he will be highly successful
as a coach someday this team needed the
voice and the coaching of emayodoka to
get to where they are right now
the lakers still need a coach
what are they waiting for
are you available
no
i told them i'm not you're not no um i'm
not
who are they waiting for
i don't know if they're waiting for one
specific person i don't know the answer
to that
um
i do know they are not from talking to
coaching agents they are not
operating with any sense of urgency they
they don't seem to believe
that they need to hire someone in the
next
couple of days couple of weeks
uh there's no real timetable from what
i've been able to gather about who the
when the lakers want to hire a coach um
and i gotta give them credit chris for
their consistency because they didn't
play with any urgency last year during
the season so why have urgency trying to
find a head coach well you'd think too
like
you know the liquor like we know the
lakers draft situation it's it's not
great but you're going into the
nba draft combine this week in chicago i
mean you theoretically want to have your
head coach in place at that point to
start thinking about kind of what you
want to do with that roster um
i don't know
yet what the future of quinn snyder is
there seems to be
i mean he hasn't been fired so he's
still there uh doc rivers is going to be
back perhaps the lakers are waiting to
see how that shook out in in
philadelphia but daryl mori uh this week
said doc rivers would be back as head
coach maybe they're waiting to see some
of these how some of these dominoes fall
with some of the more experienced
coaches
before they uh they make their pick but
i i all i can tell you dan is that
but
coach that are interviewing with the
lakers are not getting the sense there's
any urgency to fill that position
great to talk to you again chris thanks
for joining us you got it dan